no aspetta che cambio maglia sempre
uguale ai saperi bari volevo fare questa
intro nuove perché sono sempre bella
tutti ragazzi sempre la stessa ora
finalmente tornano le storielle perché
oggi non tratta un argomento come al
solito come sto facendo questi giorni
bensì vi racconto un aneddoto che è
successo durante la mia permanenza in
canada adesso vi dico sta roba perché
meritava di essere lo strumento in un
video le mie storielle li rocket league
non so se avete presente ecco questa ne
fa parte visto che non sto facendo
gameplay però in questo periodo non la
faccio solo che ti riguarda racconto
quale ero in canada ci sono stato dal 15
di settembre fino ai primi di ottobre
più o meno e stata una bellissima
vacanza per una meravigliosa vacanza
me la porterò sempre nel cuore e sono
successe delle cose
strane sono stati ospitati in canada da
degli amici il canada è un po è
veramente grossi cae grosso quindi per
muoversi in canada devi per forza avere
la macchina perché se no se vuoi fare un
viaggio un po itinerario non puoi fare
niente se non è la macchina meno che non
prendi un treno però secondo me è
difficile dal momento in cui tu vuoi
esplorare montagne cose perché il canale
è bello proprio perchè è vasto e a un
environment proprio bellissimo sono
andati in canada sono stato ospitato da
gente che vive in canada e siamo andati
a prendere la macchina cene a noleggiare
per una macchina esiste questo servizio
di car rental che ti da questa macchina
giornalmente te la fa pagare costa anche
un sacco di soldi ci siamo organizzati
per fare questi diversi viaggi ok tutti
staccati gli uni dagli altri non siamo
partiti un giorno ci siamo fatti dei
giri proprio siamo andati e tornati
andati e tornati andati torna al primo
giorno di viaggio
arriviamo lì a servizi di car rental
eravamo noi avevamo la base a toronto in
canada ok quindi noi ci dobbiamo
spostare per questo primo viaggio
dobbiamo andare a blue mountains che è
una location a tre ore di macchina dal
in piccola parentesi nessuno dei miei
mici in canada aveva la patente ok
quindi l'unico per lavorare ero io se tu
vivi in canada devi avere la patente
canadese ok se tu sei un visitatore
esterno quindi tipo io puoi guidare per
i primi tre mesi in cui sei in canada
sai ovviamente la patente
del tuo paese io ce l'ho finalmente
andiamo questo in questo servizio di
current al entriamo buongiorno
buongiorno volevo noleggiare una
macchina sì sì sì sì da c pure la
patente il passaporto
e la carta per pagare ovviamente patente
passaporto carta gliela do va bene va
bene venite che vi porto alla macchina
ci porta alla macchina fa per suoi pare
la mia carta per pagare la macchina e la
mia carta e non funziona ok non funziona
non parte strano perché i soldi sopra
c'erano l'aveva utilizzata anche quel
giorno quindi niente che non andava però
la la carta la sua età e non funziona ma
non sappiamo perché non funziona
utilizziamo la carta di questo mio amico
ok prendiamo la carta di questo amico la
sua e piano è la sua funzione perfetto
ci davano la macchina prendiamo e ce la
prendiamo la macchina e ce l'andiamo a
blu monte piove che dio la manda thaci
ha più avuto tutto il tempo ho guidato
per tre ore con la pioggia incredibile
torrenziale aria molin piovevano una
maniera incredibile usciamo dalla
macchina minchia che freddo entriamo
dentro e tre ore di nuovo per tornare e
gli ha riconsegnato questo è stato il
primo viaggio in macchina in canada ci è
andata male questo primo viaggio ma c'è
anche il secondo siamo sempre noi
vogliamo portare la macchina oggi
andiamo in un altro posto non piove non
più o non sta piovendo qui ne andiamo sì
sì sì darci la patente tutto però ci
dobbiamo dire una cosa dimmi
sostanzialmente la prima volta ti
abbiamo dato la macchina però in teoria
non avremmo potuto dartela perché chi
guida deve pagare lui non la carta di
credito del tuo amico perché se io
dovessi che ne sono rubare la macchina
non possono scalare i soldi al mio amico
di dono scalare a me perché io dando i
documenti ho dato io la garanzia quindi
se io rubo la macchina allo sfascio e
ricade su di me è ok quindi io devo dare
la mia carta e gli ho detto ecco tieni e
prendi la era mia però non funzionavano
a non funziona perché questa carta è una
carta prepagata tu devi dare una carta
di credito
ok perché la prepagata funziona che tu
metti i soldi sopra più di quelli non ti
possono togliere ok devi proprio dare
una carta di credito e la ca de grada
non ce l'avevo ce l'aveva solo il mio
amico quindi non potevamo fare niente
perchè lui non può a guidare perché
aveva la patente io non avevo la carta
di credito quindi dovevo per forza usare
la mia patente e la sua carta non
c'erano altri modi ok e vabbé non
possiamo darvi la macchina però vabbè
per questa volta facciamo un'eccezione
viviamo la macchina lo stesso però
riportate seriano rubata
grazie averci fatto questa precisazione
se avessimo voluto rubare la macchina di
sicuro adesso non avremmo rubato abbiamo
preso sta macchina e siamo andati
algonquin park si chiamava questo
mosquera tipo a 4 ore di distanza ok 4
l'andare 4 ora tornare bellissimo
montagny incredibili foreste non ha
piovuto quindi viaggio incredibile
torniamo e riconsegniamo la macchina
grazie grazie gentile arriviamo al
momento incredibile del video terzo
viaggio torniamo lì dentro buongiorno
vorremmo collegare la macchina oggi
andiamo a fare un viaggio grande oggi
andiamo a montreal 9 dice morale da
parte francese di cane del quebec
andiamo 9 all sono sei ore di viaggio
andata a sei ore di viaggio ritorno
quindi devo guidare io
devo guidare avevo le valigie perché
saremmo rimasti lì tre giorni anche
quindi avevamo tutti le valigie carichi
di valigie proprio incredibili arriva
molin eccoci qua ecco patente passaporto
la catena no no no no stavolta la
macchina noi non ve la diamo
fermi tutti piccola vi prego abbiamo le
valigie per favore c'è l'ultima l'ultimo
viaggio e non può non dobbiamo farne più
no non ve la diamo perché non si può
fare per policy ve l'abbiamo già data
diverse volte non si può fare non ama la
potevamo dare neanche l'altra volta la
macchia non ve la diamo anaya non potevo
guidare questa macchina
per andare il dato con le valigie norm
in casino perché l'altra volta non a
valle valigie perché sarà un santo arti
giornata quella volta lì saremo rimasti
a montreal per giorni quindi come
facciamo siccome quel servizio di
current al è molto conosciuto non è un
franchise c'erano altre sedili a toronto
allora guardo la sede più vicina
a quella dove stavamo no che stava tipo
neanche troppo distanti 4 3 400 metri
quindi abbastanza vicina e dico ragazzi
sentito a me da buon italiano veloce per
risolvere andiamo
altra sede e facciamo gli gnorri ok
entriamo e cerchiamo di prendere una
macchina facendo finta di non sapere che
non si può pagare con la prepagata
eccetera proviamo andiamo entro
nell'altra sede dei servizi carenti
buongiorno giorno si ecco vorremmo non è
già una macchina e con la patente
passaporto e la mia bellissima carta
tieni bellissimo tieni papa siamo pronti
carichi hours ago le valigie pazzesco
quello fa
mette su questo non ci conosceva
ovviamente ci ha mai visto mette sul
database ok prova sulla parola carte fa
a non funziona questa era tranquillo ce
ne abbiamo un'altra quale mio amico
eccola qua a te ah ok è però ragazzi non
potrei suoi parvi questa carta qua
perché non è tua che stai dando la
patente però vabbè per questa volta
facciamo un'eccezione ci ha detto questo
noi
let's go prendiamo questa macchina e
andiamo a 9 a bellissima velocità
incredibile tra l'altro bellissima ci
piace talmente tanto che decidiamo di
rimanere un giorno in più avremmo dovuto
riportarla macchina il venerdì ok però
noi venerdì saremmo voluti rimanere un
altro giorno a monte da allora cosa
abbiamo fatto abbiamo chiamato il
servizio di car sharing di current al e
abbiamo detto salve vorrei mettere la
macchina un giorno in più è possibile ci
rispondono sì sì sì tranquilli nessun
problema però noi sarà riportate sabato
siamo chiusi quindi dovete portarla al
servizio di current al vicino al nostro
che era quello di prima quello che se
non ci volevano più dare una macchina
quindi noi il sabato siamo tornati con
la macchi nel current al quello che non
c'e la voleva dare sono entrato nel
carrello fatto quel giorno questi ma
guardate come dire
il cazzo gli ha dato la macchina è
questo le chiavi charlie ed è corso via
per il fortissimo bellis è anche stato
io mi vergognavo talmente tanto ho detto
ragazzi truccate mi cioè fatemi sembrare
un'altra persino voglio entrare dentro
con le sembianze non voglio essere
riconosciuto abbiamo provato a trucca
bio giuro provato abbiamo provato a
truccarmi ho detto si vede che sono io e
faccio ridere quindi no facciamo niente
trucco vediamo che succede la storia non
finisce qui signore e signori e no
perché c'è ancora una picchetta da
giungere alla fine che non è neanche da
poco mentre io ero in canada quindi nel
mentre che è successa tutta questa roba
cosa succede io in canada
ho tolto la sim dal telefono perché
perché tanto non utilizzavo
niente cioè non lo utilizzavo il
telefono lo utilizzavo col wifi quindi
io siccome sono un paranoico ok io sono
paranoico avevo paura che si attivassero
i dati della sim qui quindi mi chiedesse
il sacco di soldi no perché maghetti
agganci alla rete all'estero quindi io
cosa ho fatto da buon paranoico ho tolto
la sim o che ho tolto la mia sim dal
telefono e l'ho messa dove adesso vi
faccio vedere un'omessa aspetta la
l'isola messa nel portamonete questo qua
portamonete
l'omessa dopo un secondo che l'omessa
nel portamento detto no la perdo io mi
con io mi conosco voi mi conosce tra
l'altro
e sapete benissimo io perdo le cose io
la perdo sta roba quindi la tolgo dal
portamonete e la metto qua la metto
dentro la patente qua dentro messa qua
dentro c'è proprio imperdibile dentro la
custodia della patente che sta dentro il
portafoglio che è chiuso non la posso
perdere
però io mi chiamo fa vj e riesco a
perderla uguale realtà non la perdo io
ma siccome sono stato premurosissima
stavolta mela perdono loro
quelli del current al perché nel
togliere la patente dal mio dal mio coso
porta patente me l'hanno sfilata
premente cascata la sim e io a un certo
punto durante la vacanza ma proprio
perché sono io ho detto no controlliamo
un po la sim come sta come se sei ruote
come sta
guardo e non c'è più
è il mio cervello ha fatto due più due
ho detto a me
torno in italia
torno in italia e sentendo un po di
amici ma ha detto guarda a mia mamma
avevano rubato la borsa col telefono
dentro è andata nel centro per rifarsi
da simili hanno gli hanno ridato il
numero l'offerta tutto l'anno ridato
quindi ho fatto la stessa cosa arrivo in
italia
vado nel centro vodafone vado a genova
salve ho perso la sim hai smarrito il
telefono no perso proprio la solo alla
sim
come mi guardano come hai fatto a
perdere la sim e basta e rifarci guardi
la ci sta comunque non te la posso fare
perché devi fare la denuncia ai
carabinieri
vado dai carabinieri buongiorno a ostuni
perso portafoglio che soprattutto la
carta d'identità avrei perso un altra
volta no guardi agente stavolta no
perché stavolta novità ho perso la sim
stavolta la sim card vieni vieni che ti
faccio fare il foglio della denuncia dal
mio collega vabbè mi siedo mi fa nome e
cognome e io
lorenzo ostuni ok cos'hai smarrito io ho
smarrito la sera sim card ma si
smarrisce sim card quando l'hai smarrita
e io guardi non ho proprio il giorno
preciso però ho un range di tempo se
vuole ora lascia stare tempo e luogo
dello smarrimento ignoti ma guardi che
io quando l'ho smarrita non lo so ma il
luogo lo so lui mi guarda e mi fa e
quando pensavi di dirmelo tu quando mai
chiesta non è che mai chiesto che si fa
dov'è che lei smarrita
in canada luogo dello smarrimento canada
ma sim che la una sim card che è così
così
canada bellissimo i ragazzi questo è
stata la mia esperienza incredibile in
canada meraviglioso ricordate non
mettete la sim in giro perché tanto se
tanto il canada se la prende ti portavi
a tutto il canada tutto però vi sia
piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale lasciate
un bel commento mi piace occhio ai team
citiamo il prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]